hello and welcome to this video playing
Zach Dawa who the heck is Zach bawa he's
got really high ratings there and I've
never played him okay so some reversed
tirage dope goes for the noni it's
essentially a benoni a temple up modern
baloney attempt art but it doesn't
necessarily mean that it is bad for
white temple isn't super important
sometimes
yes hi it was my idea clearing against
some space here interesting I like my
position here
hmm yeah do I get in b5 somehow I just
wonder if it he has some loose pieces
I'm d 3 and so on if maybe and b5 can be
played immediately and be probably not
probably will go a five lets you move
that I thought wasn't wasn't good so yes
let's see maybe should be three doesn't
work I can take you for
let's shake here looks like a shaky
position the Rope is hanging and that's
resin to take and take f1
yeah that just gives me the pawn and d4
hangs admittedly the f4 hangs self but I
mean d6 also might hang we'll see what
he does now but I think I can just take
with the Queen here next
we take the foils the next move almost
regardless hmm I cannot do I can also
play the chick here and then take on e4
and then take F for that also make sense
but I don't think there's something
wrong with this either you cannot okay
you can take a body cannot take okay so
g5 maybe so that I have the or just go
back and just just go back is good to f6
and one day I should go f 4 in this
position yeah maybe just keep this on
the boards and this is a week porn and
the moment I play it is the moment I
regretted him I have a static just light
at six and he's probably just falling
apart and before is annoying I mean I
saw it just just at a too late ok so if
you just stand i take i put the bishop
bag let's do it
actually just taken and that would have
been extremely easy okay I mean don't
take it not playing f4
you fighters hanging he's got Bishop c4
Scott Bishop c4 time warning check
yeah I have to have misplayed this
terribly that was just a completely
winning position and this is now nothing
nothing clear
but what did he do that how did he
manage that how did she what did you do
I had was some kind of kind of
fascinated yeah I didn't didn't see what
he was doing how he was able to do that
and now we can just take and maybe I'm
completely off completely yeah the
hollow see how did he what did he do we
took with the other with the other look
I mean I really I really don't mind the
end I'm just an idiot damn just I just
just take this and this this game is
basically done yeah just open the
position and win with the pawn and not
give him this is ridiculous rupee one
before and so on ridiculous the wrong
move but it's ridiculous that I allow it
yeah because it's just much more
difficult now to play no no this is not
easy at all okay yeah in White House
excellent compensation it's much easier
to play with white it didn't quite
understand what happened that he could
take this it irritated me to no end I
mean plus in well an extremely clean
start and then allowing this was pretty
terrible okay thanks for watching